temporary sushi and they incorporate
non-traditional ingredients and latin
american from
ingredients from latin america and
europe for bold and unique menus and
joining us in the kitchen today is
executive chef of sushi roku chef
takashita and general manager johnny saw
welcome you two thank you so much for
joining us today i'm just looking here
my mouth is watering what is oh sushi
roku is really a staple in las vegas
johnny tell us a little bit where you're
located what are your hours how can
people find sushi roaches yes sushi look
it's located on the third level of the
seizures palace forum shops
we open seven days dinner from the four
to close and
the lunch
during the friday saturday sunday three
days and also we have a happy hour as
well oh great amazing happy hour most
popular happier on the street
and
chef
haruhi
like [ __ ] i will not introduce a seven
star roll today this spring special this
is a special row this is a special room
show us chef what do you have i'm
looking at the ingredients this is
absolutely beautiful but this i can't
imagine the flavors that you're putting
together so we got a wagyubi from
miyazaki japan
and toto the tuna belly from the uh
mexico
wow just those two things alone
is enough but then what else do you put
in truffle
okay okay so
what i have a roll here is a total
cucumber jalapeno inside
and
wagyu beef on the top
here like that
these are all flavors
that stand on their own you're putting
them together we're adding a little fire
to them yeah
how do you come up with these ideas
i just come up with the ideas this the
inspiration is amazing i got uh wasabi
soy truffle
and a little bit of that on top top
then
truffle
this is a delicacy
france
see if i wanted to take this home can i
order this and and
pick it up of course of course you know
not only for this one we have a sushi
special sushi box and fish deluxe box
and also we have family pack
this is a amazing most popular role
signature here so you won't be
disappointed you're ready to go
this is all available together yeah
definitely exactly yeah can i take chef
home with us
12 hours okay
okay i think there's a finishing touch
okay
right here um edible gold 24 kilo gold
just like that
that is beautiful
wow okay and if people want to order
this again what is this called seven
star roll
star is the high tier of the reward
member at the series palace the chef
create this one he is the most
passionate and creative chef
from japan the seven star roll is looks
amazing tell us about some of these
packs though what what all comes in all
of these
so we have the tuna pocky
and white lords raw white rose roll is
shrimp
avocado asparagus and avocado on top
with crispy onion comes with also the
wasabi truffle soy and edamame and we
have hanavi hanabi is one of the great
dish our specialty signature dish
hanabis by tuna
and again if you want to check out sushi
roku it is it is one of the best places
you can go to in las vegas and caesar's
palace can i taste it of course oh my
gosh
can i just use my fingers in it okay
you've never had anything so nice
oh get in trouble oh my gosh of course
this is oh you guys are so jealous this
is amazing okay who am i tossing it to
how many cocos do you have
candle oh my gosh i can die a happy
woman
kendall
that is the best thing i've ever tasted
honestly that's high praise i